it's been almost 50 years since American
Pie was the number one song in America
but it's still ubiquitous it's
everywhere
sometimes as lyrics even get referred to
on cable news shows that's the
Democratic Party's position and if
you're not sold yet
if you sense there might be a few links
missing from that logic chain Nancy
Pelosi has an answer for you it's not so
much an argument as it is a cliched bomb
a dense cluster of familiar phrases
designed to convey the impression that
important facts are being delivered and
profound thinking is taking place it's
like that old Don McLean song drove my
chevy to the levee but the levee was dry
doesn't actually mean anything but it
kind of moves you anyway
but then we started thinking about it we
realized maybe that's not fair American
pies lyrics may mean something to find
out we go to the man who wrote them
probably the most famous songwriter in
this country Don McLean joins us tonight
mr. McLain thanks so much for coming on
thank you for having me i watch your
show often well that's really thank you
I appreciate that so what this is the
question every person who's ever driven
on an American interstate has asked him
or herself where's the levee and what
does this mean what are the lyrics mean
well could I just take a moment and
explain that there are many poems and
songs and folk music
certainly that are not particularly
exactly prosaic that's right that's why
there are poetry but I had an idea I had
an idea for a big song about America and
I didn't want to write it this land is
your land or some song like that and I
came up with this notion that politics
and music flow parallel together forward
through history so the the music you get
is related somehow to the political
environment that's going on yes and in
the song American Pie this the verses
get somewhat more dire each time until
you get to the end
but the good ol boys are always there
singing and singing bye bye miss
American Pie almost like fiddling while
Rome is burning yes this was all in my
head and it sort of turned out to be
true because you now have a kind of
music in America that's really more
spectacle it owes more to Liberace than
it does to Elvis Presley and it's
somewhat meaningless and loud and
bloviating and and yet when we have this
sort of spectacle in Washington this
kind of politics which is gotten so out
of control and so the theory seems to
hold up but again it was only my theory
and that's how I wrote the song that was
the principle behind them so you set out
to write as you said a big song about
America and boy did you succeed fifty
years fifty years later you know it's
one of the most famous songs ever
written in English and one of the most
resilient and resident I mean we're
still listening to it every day what
kind of reaction do you get from people
to the song now well I always did the
song has been part of their lives now
you know I'm part of their lives and and
my the albums that I made in the 1970s
go along with that but of course that
the kingpin is the song American Pie
yeah and really all roads lead to Rome
in my show I sing the American Songbook
songs that I've written whether it's
castles in the air' and I love you so
Vincent
yes wonderful baby all these winter
would best all roads lead to American
Pie at the end usually and it's a
summing up of everything that's going on
I don't really do a set you know I've
been doing this for so many years that I
kind of make up I do a new show every
night but could I just tell you one
thing about yourself that I've noticed
and that is that you do something that
nobody else does you get a guest on and
then you ask them a core
question and I think that nobody else
that does that it's a very well thought
out question and nine times out of ten
the guest can't answer it which is makes
it very amusing and fun because you
don't get into a whole thing of going
everywhere he wants to go you make him
come to that question
that's very philosophical that's that's
Socratic and I love that I think that's
terrific well I really actually the
basics are what matter to me
I'm a very basic person like a dog Donna
clay it is an honor to have you on
tonight thank you so much I can't tell
you the number of thank you I've thought
about you alone in the car and it's it's
great to finally meet you thanks very
much well thank you for having me